you are a Hillary supporter have been  for I've known her almost as long as  I've known you  so make oh okay same amount of time okay  she was a she we started together as  writers on the show that question what  does she what's response did she have a  sense of humor is she funny she's  actually very funny  yeah she's it's very odd in in  one-on-one or in small things she is one  of the most present people she listens  and she's got a goofy sense of humor her  husband is not very funny  he's nm he's n F cheese F yeah by using  those yeah she is a toughest most  experienced hardest-working person I  know and you know I trust her to do this  job this is a tough job I've seen it  kind of up close a little more up close  than I thought I ever would when we were  at 30 rock and it's a really really  tough job  you